much awaited it is time for hatred mail
here is a reminder about what hatred
mail is because we cling to our guns and
our God but somehow totally cool with a
billionaire who wants to assault our
wife Patriot man
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom all right not much by way of an
introduction in this week's hatred mail
other than to say possibly possibly the
longest run on sentence that we've ever
received in hatred mail Parkman's sock
puppets fake news lies who has their
hand up your ass DNC is KKK embedded by
the Dems 1865 and going strong
Antipas stormtroopers of the DNC KKK
death to Antipas last DNC terror Obama
KKK Isis Muslim take the red pill and
there goes our tax monies now the way
that it was read by the hatred of the
voice of Patriot mail had some pauses
that might imply to you that there was
actually some punctuation but not a
single comma or period arguably the
longest run on sentence in the history
of hatred mail and all caps by the way
that wasn't a touch that we added we
present these to you exactly as they
come in and the all caps hate mail sort
of the calling card of right-wing
hatreds you can turn hatred mail into
something positive we've got a coupon
code which is hey tree at forty that
will save you forty percent off of your
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership and it is spelled h atri o t
forty give the middle finger to the hey
treats by using the coupon code hey tree
at forty